the scp foundation's hallowed halls have
been the site of many great and puzzling
mysteries among them being who was the
true creator of scp-173
the neck snapping sculpture what are the
secrets that dr alto clef is keeping
about his past who are the true seven
children of the scarlet king who was as
cp106 the old man before he got all
nasty and of course what is the true
nature and origin of scp-096
the violent terrifying and incredibly
withdrawn shy guy it's a question so
great that we knew even our experts here
at scp-explained couldn't take on the
mission alone that's why we pooled the
resources of you the loyal viewers of
scp explain to find the answer we made a
community post asking for your personal
theories on how the shy guy came to be
and you didn't disappoint sending in a
cavacade of curious conjecture that we
just can't wait to explore so let's hop
right in and see what all of you had to
say here is puffy shades theory he was a
lost british d-class named martin
mcgregor on a risky experiment in
colombia regarding scp-1290
a d-class prisoner was teleported to an
unknown mountainous location after a
malfunction in the device he stayed
there for 37 hours before dying of his
bullet wounds from being shot by foreign
soldiers wherever the d-class was
teleported to was a foreign country not
welcomed to outsiders as we know there
have been some scps that have escaped
the grasp of the foundation the
foundation has located them but never
been able to see or capture them
continuing with the story it is
speculated that one of these entities
that is still undiscovered had the power
of necromancy they brought the d class
back to the mortal world but in an
immortal form to terrorize humanity
forever the entity brings humans back to
life as supernatural beings their powers
being determined by their former
personality the resurrected d-class was
always shy self-conscious of his
unattractive face as you can probably
guess this resulted in the birth of our
good old friend shy guy certainly a
fascinating direction to go with the
basis in recorded anomalous activity and
much like a few other anomalies
originating from d-class personnel such
as
scp-2419 the laughing men and scp-4900
the dead men walking it would feel oddly
satisfying to see another one of the
foundation's greatest mistakes become
one of the gravest threats here is
diamond star lemon's theory the shy guy
was andrew ravine one of the two
mountaineers that went missing who were
part of the british expedition that was
sent to reach the top of mount everest
in 1924
while andrew and his friend george
mallory were heading for camp 5 they
encountered
scp-1529 at different intervals
since mallory's body was eventually
found in 1999 this tells us that irvine
also encountered 15-29
ravine constantly rejected 1529's offers
and eventually developed a defense
mechanism where he gets aggressive and
attacks as cp 1529 in return 1529
prolonged his life by years to make him
suffer every single minute his skin
turned white due to constant exposure to
the sun and he took all of his clothes
off due to hypothermia this is confirmed
because mallory's body was just as white
as hervine and a letter he said to his
family says that andrew became very shy
and barely speaks and he eventually
disappears mallory then encounters 15 29
and punches him in the face and then
malory falls unconscious leading to his
death meanwhile irvine loses his sanity
and has his body disfigured and his
hands developed claws for better
climbing this is another popular theory
which has its roots in pre-existing
anomalous knowledge the horrific
tortures by scp-1529 the mountain king
against andrew arvine is believed by
many to be the root of the shy guy's
creation of course we can't know for
sure but some compelling evidence
undeniably points in this intriguing
direction here is number one trihard's
theory i think he was one of the
subjects in the russian sleep experiment
that escaped and ran into the siberian
mountains became aware of the
monstrosity he had become and became
violently self-conscious this is a
strange and creative theory wrapping 096
in with the lore of the legendary
russian sleep experiment russia does
have its fair share of snowy mountain
ranges and the experiment did turn its
unfortunate subjects into horrifying
monsters but the nature of these
monsters did differ significantly from
the shy guy showing higher intelligence
but far less durability against physical
trauma here is avery spencer's theory i
have wondered if perhaps he was part of
an almost death love pass incident and
was the sole survivor being in such a
position he was forced to eat his
comrades he then took on almost wenigo
aspects but instead of the bloodthirsty
feelings most got he became so ashamed
of what he did he can no longer tolerate
someone looking at him this is another
incredibly interesting theory that has
its basis in both russian legend and
real life history there have been a
number of events in the snowy mountains
of russia much like the d'atlov pass
incident which have left high altitude
tragedies in their wake one of these
traumatizing its victims to the point of
them turning into an anomalous creature
like scp-096
definitely doesn't seem out of the
question here is creocol's theory shy
guy has no face his face does not exist
not in the sense that it's just smooth
skin the face is actually nothing he is
a body and mind directly attached to a
pattern screamer humans expect
humanoid-shaped creatures to have a face
thus when someone sees his face the
screamer takes over and destroys that
person so it can stop existing his body
has changed over the years to facilitate
eliminating people who see the face more
effectively this is why he wants to
disappear in the desire camera finish
being nothing so people stop filling in
his face a way it could have happened is
an incomplete encounter with 3930 the
one who became the shy guy leaned in and
just his face ceased to exist though he
probably would have already needed some
anomalous traits to survive that this is
another extremely original and
interesting theory based in pre-existing
anomalies of course there's no real way
to prove that scp-096's face isn't a
pattern screamer given that to look upon
it is to court death so we may just need
to take your word on this one here is
lens attack's theory perhaps 096 is an
alien from a planet or dimension that's
completely dark where being seen is a
death sentence because of the local
anomalous fauna he somehow wound up in
our universe perhaps 096 is cursed that
whoever sees him will eventually
transform into something much worse or
become a portal into a dark dimension
and he does us all a favor by
eliminating these people before that can
happen another two extremely interesting
theories both of which could potentially
hold water they seem consistent with the
fact that scp-096 takes no pleasure in
the killing of its victims it only seems
to be doing it out of the sense that it
feels compelled into action here is
chill me's theory he could be the
physical embodiment of the feeling of
body dysmorphia another very valid
theory given scp-096
general temperament and caustic
reactions to being perceived in any way
here is renan roman's theory what would
happen if dr bright looked at
scp-096's face i mean his host would
certainly be killed but what would
happen as soon as dr bright picks
another host would scp-096
instantaneously charge at the new host
and kill it as well hmm an interesting
theory and one that we've explored
ourselves on videos concerning dr bright
before it's another good reason that
this particular scenario should be
placed on the dr bright is not allowed
list though even though dr bright does
occasionally beg for death this is one
horrifying recursive fate that even jack
himself probably wouldn't enjoy here is
han guy's theory from what i heard there
are two theories one was that he was a
mountaineer that survived an encounter
with the king of the mountain and had to
adapt to the mountain to survive both
from him and the mountain itself or he's
actually one of the children of the
scarlet king while we've covered the
mountain king theory this scarlet king
theory is all new could scp-096 be a
child of the terrifying scarlet king
he's certainly destructive but perhaps
he lacks the true knowing malice the
sadism that make the big red armored
lunatic proud he certainly doesn't have
an abject hatred of a 682 here is claude
cat's theory i wouldn't be surprised if
he was a species and came to be that way
as it is perfectly hidden they blend in
with the snow and if anyone saw its face
to know it was there they couldn't
document it for obvious reasons this is
an interesting and terrifying concept a
whole species of shy guys this is
another good reason to ardently fight
against climate change if all the snow
melts there will be nowhere for them to
hide anymore here is dan wolf's theory
the idea of if a tree falls and no one
is around to hear it is his origin he is
the physical manifestation of all the
energy of all the things unseen the
sound of a falling tree the transparent
skin of fish in the abyssal zone
development on half-life 3 all these
things exist but they do so unseen
shy is physical manifestation of that
metaphysical energy he didn't exist
until he was seen thus he came to be
existing is painful to him so he kills
anyone who sees his face the thing we as
humans use to identify one another in a
hope to be unrecognized and unknown to
eventually no longer exist this is a
fascinating theory our one question is
how he could ever be seen if by
definition he is an avatar of the unseen
what would cause these lapses in
non-existence it raises an interesting
metaphysical quandary in and of itself
here is jonathan collier's theory the
shy guy is a creation of the plague
doctor who engineered him in the french
alps he began as a human but the
doctor's process mutated him into his
current form he designed him to destroy
the pestilence but he was infected by it
somewhere in the process this means that
whenever someone sees his face they
catch the pestilence his programming can
allow this so he is forced to destroy
whoever sees him the doctor's
programming was incomplete when he was
corrupted so he only hunts those that he
has infected with the pestilence not all
that the plague doctor deems infected
his indestructible form is a combination
of the plague doctor's tinkering and
treatments as well as the doctor
potentially incorporating dna from other
anomalous creatures such as 682 which
did visit france and lord blackwood's
tales the doctor likely kept the dna in
reserve for his ultimate device to
destroy the pestilence however it failed
and led him to releasing the shy guy to
roam the mountains traveling eventually
from the alps to the himalayas where he
was discovered the creature cries as it
kills its victims because of its human
beginnings and its apparent anxiety is
likely the lingering emotion it felt
before it was transformed leading to it
being repeated for the rest of its
existence we love the plague doctor here
at scp explained so we're always happy
to consider fun potential crossovers
featuring him with some of our other
favorite anomalies the one thing working
against this theory is that 096 is an
uncharacteristically effective creation
for the plague doctors standards most of
which are janky disfigured zombies
sorry049 here is devin linder's theory i
always felt like 096 was possessed by an
evil spirit that lives in the frost
essentially the original native story of
a wendigo it just all makes sense
deformities and strength lives in the
cold hunts and kills people i don't know
if there's anything about looking at a
wendigo in the original stories though
the algonquin myth of the wendigo
certainly does have some similarities to
scp-096
however it has a little more in common
with another anomaly
scp-320
the wendigo skull which forces its
wearers into spontaneous acts of
violence and cannibalism though if ever
096 found itself wearing the wendigo
skull we'd all be in terrible trouble
here is epic kitty 101's theory not
really a theory it's just what i want it
to be i believe that 096's actions are
derived from trauma it could very well
be a species and might be a different
version like albino so whenever someone
looks at its face it feels as though
that person was so inconvenienced by its
looks it wants to kill them because he
thinks they hate him now he believes he
isn't good enough for anyone's standards
we can all relate to that feeling now
and then and the hysteric crying and
wailing of scp-096 undeniably suggests a
level of psychological trauma one thing
we know for sure it definitely inflicts
trauma on the rest of us here is lemon
demon dangerous theory hear me out when
day breaks was actually a primitive
event and the shy guy was the result
without any people to go around for the
next several millennia the shy guy grew
fond of the lack of company ultimately
turning him into the person or monster
he is today this is a fascinating one
however there is some pre-existing
evidence such as the tale unexpected
light which we've covered in a video on
this channel that suggests scp-096
survived into the reign of scp-001 when
daybreaks though sadly according to that
tale he didn't survive beyond it here is
andrew colen's theory i have a theory he
was born with some deformities and super
strength and was mocked for it as he
grew older the deformities grew more
noticeable so maybe the years of trauma
and abuse or whatnot could have caused
him to self-isolate and attack violently
against anyone who sees him this
definitely reflects the internality that
many people believe as cp-096 has a
frightened insecure creature spiding its
own creation and anyone unfortunate
enough to look upon it though we'll
never really know how exactly it got
there here is stripey socks 101's theory
he could have been one of the scp-1000
instances but born hairless and unable
to think so was abandoned by its parents
another good cross-anomaly connection
however 096 is significantly more
durable than any member of scp-1000 as
well as having far more freakish
proportions so it's unlikely to have any
real relation to this advanced species
of apes here is blue iblis's theory well
based on his height his reaction to his
face being seen and how quick he is
scp-096 is literally just an irl
enderman they're both tall they're both
able to move quickly and become
instantly pissed if you look at their
face or eyes this probably means 096 is
maybe from another dimension but it's
just a theory we might dismiss a
potential minecraft influence out of
hand or not for the existence of
scp-4335
also known as a welt in the crucible an
evil minecraft monster however this
monster was actually the one responsible
for the enderman in minecraft due to a
foundation-inspired patch sadly
invalidating this theory here is james
bevin's theory my theory is that the shy
guy is a demon summoned by a cult that
dwelled in the mountains they hoped to
control him but were unaware that the
entity reacts violently whenever anyone
sees its face and all met a grisly death
scp-096 is undeniably rather demonic so
we couldn't argue with this theory on
that front it's also very likely that
any cult who unwittingly summons him
without the knowledge of his primary
anomalous effect would meet a truly
gruesome death at his claws and teeth so
you may be onto something here james
here is harrison o'leary's theory well
when he left the mushroom kingdom he
obviously lost his mask and clothes the
idea that the shy guy is literally well
a shy guy is certainly an intriguing one
though how 096's long gangly body could
fit in those tiny compact outfits is an
open question if only researcher mario
and researcher luigi would take some
time off of their extremely busy
schedules to help us out with that one
oh no
oh
not luigi time here is roninsky's theory
he was a very handsome man who was
experimented on and now goes into
violent fits of rage when people look at
his now disfigured face
is it just us or is the idea of a
strangely handsome scp-096 somehow even
more disturbing than the one we already
have just feels so unnatural which one
of these wild theories do you think was
your favorite do you have a stunning
revelation we haven't covered here feel
free to let us know down in the comments
and of course keep an eye on our
community tab for fun new questions if
you too want the chance to be featured
in a video like this in the future now
go check out scp-096 shy guy escape
incident
096-1-8 containment breach and scp-096
look at a picture of shy guy in space
the shy guy questions and theories for
more of this singularly enigmatic
anomalous introvert